lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
relacionar el desplazamiento angular y
la longitud de arco o la distancia
recorrida imaginemos que aquí tenemos
una pelota de tenis que está atada
mediante una cuerda a un clavo
si queremos mover esta pelota lo que
hará será rotar alrededor del clavo y se
moverá en esta trayectoria circular azul
digamos que la longitud del radio de
este círculo azul es de 6 metros que es
la longitud de la cuerda si comenzamos
aquí nuestro ángulo inicial que por
convención medimos a partir de la parte
positiva del eje x va a ser igual a pi
entre 2 y digamos que vamos a rotar los
dos y radiales positivos rotamos la
pelota en sentido antihorario 2 irradian
es y la pelota llegará al mismo lugar
que estaba al principio de tal final va
a ser igual a 2 pi más estudia acá lo
que nos da 5 pi entre 2 también
mencionamos que rotamos la pelota en
dirección positiva que es en sentido
antihorario y dijimos que rotamos 2p y
radiales así que tenemos la respuesta de
cuál fue él
aplazamiento angular de la teta va a ser
igual a 2 y radiant es la segunda
pregunta que vamos a hacer es cuál es la
distancia recorrida por la pelota
recuerden que al hablar de distancia nos
interesa la trayectoria recorrida y la
distancia recorrida es la circunferencia
de este círculo pausa en el vídeo y
reflexionen sobre lo que significa este
recorrido también traten de pensar en
cuál será el desplazamiento de esta
pelota supongo que ya reflexionaron
sobre esto y la respuesta más sencilla
es darnos cuenta de que la pelota inició
y terminó en el mismo lugar por lo que
el desplazamiento de esta pelota es cero
al menos si pensamos en el
desplazamiento tradicional si nos
referimos al desplazamiento angular es 2
y radiant es y cuál es la distancia
denotamos la distancia con la letra s
mayúscula que también podemos ver como
la longitud de arco en este caso el arco
es todo el círculo a que será igual
sabemos por las clases de geometría que
hemos visto que esto es la
circunferencia del círculo 2 y por el
radio
es igual a 2 x 6 metros lo que nos da 12
pi metros que es la distancia recorrida
aquí lo interesante al menos en este
caso particular es que para encontrar la
distancia recorrida o la longitud de
arco tomamos nuestro desplazamiento
angular o mejor dicho la magnitud del
desplazamiento angular podemos verlo
como el valor absoluto de esto y lo
multiplicamos por el radio de nuestro
círculo r es la longitud de nuestra
cuerda por lo que multiplicamos esto por
r esta es nuestra longitud de arco en
este caso tenemos la magnitud del cambio
en el desplazamiento multiplicado por el
radio veamos
si esto se cumple siempre en este caso
tengo una pelota atada con una cuerda de
tres metros de longitud su ángulo
inicial es pi radiales como podemos ver
aquí y ahora digamos que la pelota va a
rotar en sentido horario nuestra teta
final espí entre dos radiales pausa en
el vídeo y traten de calcular el
desplazamiento angular en esta situación
el desplazamiento angular es igual a
theta final
espí entre 2 - theta inicial que speed
esto es igual a menos pi entre 2 tiene
sentido esto sí porque la rotación no
fue en sentido horario y mencionamos que
la rotación en sentido horario siempre
será negativa así que coincide con lo
que tenemos aquí una rotación en sentido
horario de pi entre 2 ahora con base en
la información que acabamos de calcular
vean si pueden encontrar la longitud de
arco recorrida por esta pelota atada con
una cuerda de 3 metros de longitud que
será igual esta distancia hay un par de
formas de pensar en esto pueden decir
que esto es una cuarta parte de la
circunferencia así que pueden decir que
ese es igual a un cuarto por dos y por
el radio que es 3 con esto obtendremos
la respuesta correcta 2 por un cuarto es
un medio por pi por 3 nos da tres pi
entre dos metros pero ahora veamos si
esto es consistente con la fórmula que
definimos acá esto es lo mismo que tomar
el valor absoluto del desplazamiento
angular
lo escribimos y multiplicarlo por el
radio que es de 3 metros en efecto estas
dos cosas son iguales
esto es pi entre dos positivos por tres
que es igual a tres pies entre dos
parece que esta fórmula está funcionando
bastante bien tiene sentido porque si
tenemos la circunferencia tradicional
que es 2 pipo radio y pensamos en cuál
es la proporción del círculo que
representa esta longitud de arco la
proporción es la magnitud del
desplazamiento angular es la proporción
de la circunferencia que se recurrió al
rotar la pelota si esto es 2 pi
entonces será toda la circunferencia si
es pi será la mitad de la circunferencia
pero noten que estas dos cosas se
cancelan por lo que nos queda la fórmula
que encontramos para calcular la
longitud de arco hagamos otro ejemplo
digamos que la cuerda que sujeta la
pelota tiene una longitud de 5 metros el
ángulo inicial spears entre 6 radiales y
el ángulo final está justo aquí y es
igual a pie entre 3
base en todo lo que hemos comentado cuál
es la distancia recorrida por la pelota
cuál es la longitud de arco primero
tenemos que encontrar el desplazamiento
angular este va a ser igual a theta
final que spears entre 3 - theta inicial
que spears entre 6 que es igual a pie
entre 6 para llegar a este punto rotamos
la pelota en sentido antihorario con un
ángulo de pi entre 6 radiales con esto
vamos a calcular la longitud de arco
multiplicando esto por el radio la
longitud de arco es igual a pie entre 6
por el radio que es 5 metros lo que nos
da 5 pi entre 6 metros así encontramos
la longitud de arco aquí no hay nada
mágico
esto viene directamente de la idea de la
circunferencia de un círculo
nos vemos en otro vídeo